let's go back to the phones and see
what's on folks minds let's try going to
a caller from Skype that's always it can
be dicey sometimes it's an international
caller sometimes it's a troll but a
Skype caller you are on who's this hi
David
yes hi David my name is Antonio um I had
a question more of a concern about a
oldest story that you did a few weeks
maybe even a month or so back regarding
national OU's National Academy of
Science study I read several articles on
it tried to actually read through the
whole study itself about Trump voters
and what their motivations were and the
conclusion of the study was that their
concerns were not based upon their
economics or their economic situation
but rather than a sense that they were
losing their status do you remember that
I do so Antonio you sound out of breath
so I'll just I'll give you a second to
catch your breath and we'll explain to
the audience you're referring to a study
which pointed out that for many Trump
voters a primary motivation for voting
for Trump was that they were concerned
about losing status in society in a
variety of different ways and they
sought Trump as the guy who would
protect their status that that was the
conclusion of the studies sorry for
being out of breath I had to run no
problem you came up no no problem how
could I not really an offer already set
on the story yet yeah you said you were
doing a hard break in them about a
second later you can't took my call but
basically my concern was yes that it was
being reported let's not just your own a
very surface level did an illustration
listen Antonio I don't know if you just
put us on speaker but we're only getting
every third word now is there like is
there a very specific question about
that study that you had yeah well no
it's not a question about the study I'm
Mike Mike my concern is about the way
it's being reported okay seems to me
that you're making the same mistake
that the bell-curve people make where
they're not looking at the environmental
issues regarding that just a quick like
I said a quick illustration where did
time worked at a call center I was a top
producer and at the time we were all
producing at record levels but for some
reason we weren't getting raises okay
then all of a sudden these complaints a
screen magically appeared that started
telling everybody when they're when
calls weren't being taken who was off
who was on break who was on lunch and
before you knew it we all started
turning on each other and me being a top
producer I was lucky enough to be right
underneath this screen and people
started coming in complaining right
around my cubicle and when I asked them
to leave they started asking questions
about me
my point is yeah is that they're not
people aren't wrong about what their
status people aren't wrong that well
half of Americans are making 30 grand a
year or less but what's happening is
they're being manipulated into blaming
others who were more or less going
through the same situation and not
blaming the right people the people who
are not right raising their wages the
people are taking all their money away
from them the people who are rigging the
system against them yes what's the
disagreement what's your concern I mean
that's exactly what the study the study
didn't say no objectively they were lose
they feared they're losing their status
to these other people but they are
losing their status they're just being
manipulated to blame the wrong people
and the study is being used and to
justify that Trump voters or somehow
raised this or whatever else and no
losing status doesn't run anybody's
raises listen Antonio I'm sorry I'm
having a real hard time we're not we're
not getting to any place where I think
there would be like a logical follow-up
so I'll review the study and I just I'm
not sure I understand your point but I
do really
appreciate you taking the time to to
call in